fa così fa
così destra
[Applauso]
[Musica]
dest Oddio Aspetta ti aiuto Ioa
Challenge scuola nella vita reale
secchioni contro
Bulli Chi vincerà la Challenge vincerà
il mio nuovissimo libro La città
stregata agli investigatori del mistero
che è ora disponibile onl in tutte le
librerie voi ce l'avete Se non ce
l'avete andate subito a prenderlo e mi
raccomando lasciate un bel mi piace
iniziamo subito la
Challenge Io sono Lidia e la mia abilità
è imparare tutto quello che
[Musica]
leggo Io sono Anita e faccio parte del
team dei
secchioni e la mia abilità è risolvere i
misteri come nel nuovo libro in cui c'è
un nuovissimo mistero da risolvere voi
potete provare a risolverlo insieme a
noi infatti se non ce l'avete andate
subito a prenderlo e dentro c'è anche
l'alfabeto segreto ma ora il libro lo
vincerà solo chi vincerà questa
Challenge Infatti verrà custodito nella
prigione di massima sicurezza e chiunque
si avvicinerà riceverà una Scosta da
1000 vol Io sono gny so fare benissimo
il caco la matematica per esempio 1 + 1
2 Ovviamente faccio parte del team dei
secchi
[Musica]
occhioni Eccomi io sono Billy del team
dei bulli e anche oggi farò scappare
tutti i
secchioni Io sono Jack del Zin dei bulli
e anche se sono un po' stupido faccio
degli scherzi
indimenticabili
io sono Frank del team dei bulli e posso
far sparire qualsiasi cosa come i
compiti dei
secchioni Oh no mi fanno paura Uffa
Eccoli tornati i bulli no i miei compiti
No no no Sono quello che TAC tengo di
più Allora io mio Qui no io al centro ci
sta il capo
no
[Musica]
Allora ragazzi siamo Pronti prontissimi
un altro giorno di scherzi è arrivato Sì
sì si sente proprio che sono arrivati i
bulli state facendo troppo casino
ragazzi miei Oggi è la giornata perfetta
per fare un sacco di scherzi divertenti
è quello che ci piace
fare ma insomma fate silenzio dobbiamo
studiare noi dobbiamo
concentrarci la verifica Sì siamo
prontissimi perché noi siamo i secchioni
abbiamo studiato tantissimo lo vinceremo
noi il libro e già il
nostro ci siamo troppo
forti Eh ma ragazzi come facciamo a fare
la verifica io c'ho solo la penna Io
solo la gna Io solo il quaderno ma
perché questo quaderno È cosa tu sei un
bullo ma di tre non ne facciamo uno non
so neanche scrivere io oh neanche io so
scrivere
brav tu sei scrivere
No ragazzi Ragazzi ma se andassimo a
fare degli scherzi ai secchioni
D'altronde è la nostra
specialità siamo già 3 minuti in classe
non abbiamo ancora fatto uno scherzo
andiamo dobiamo redare
subito fa i Bui stanno facendo troppo
rumore non riesco a concentrarmi basta
per favore come si fa a fare una
verifica così è
impossibile Guarda
questo sei brutto guarda
fantastico Vabbè vabbè ma non dobbiamo
fare gli scherzi fra di noi dobbiamo
farli a loro ai secchioni
Sì ho un'idea perché non andiamo nella
classe Sì avete ragione Andiamocene
Addio Bulli noi ce ne andiamo perché
fate troppo rumore Ciao ragazzi Abbiamo
fatto andare via ai secchioni Sì la
classe è
nostra tempo abbiamo più tempo per
organizzare i nostri scherzi Uh tiriamo
fuori tutti i nostri giochetti e poi
andiamo dalle
secchione Mi è venuta un'idea il mio
topo non è è un topo normale è un topo
telecomandato bello e quindi lo potrei
mandare dalle secchione a sciare i loro
compiti con i suoi occhietti e magari
anche a farle
spaventare
[Applauso]
F che schifo Fa paura anche a me qu sono
si
chion gi più Uff della scuola
ragazze Lo sentite il silenzio Sì
finalmente Adesso sì che possiamo
concentrarci sul tema Senza quei Bulli
non vedoa di avere quel libro in
mano erano proprio insopportabili Eh sì
noi dobbiamo vincere dobbiamo vincerlo
noi il libro
assolutamente bene Ragazzi allora con
quale scherzo iniziamo a terrorizzare i
secchioni Io ho un pipistrello F
possiamo farle spaventare
tantissimo fantastico e tu quale scherzo
hai Io ho la cacca No fantastico vè
mitico No ragazzi oggi vi stupirò io
guardate cosa ho un topo
telecomandato ha posto degli occhi alle
telecamere fantastico In questo modo
possiamo copiare i compiti delle
secchione esatto e vinceremo il libro il
libro di Anita Sì dai ragazzi ce la
possiamo fare andiamo
andiamo guida guida così poi io scrivo
qua quello che Copiamo Fai così fai così
destra destra destra destra destra sì io
son pronto dai ok Così su così ti sbatti
così ti sbatti al pied occhio non ti
SB Che schifo che
scho too c'è un too c' uno Ok vien qui
veloci attenzione Adesso cerca di farlo
salire dobbiamo riuscire a inquadrare il
compito per poi ricopiarlo sì così
scrivo tutto qua dai dai dai orola su Sì
bravo
[Applauso]
avanti Eccoci siamo arrivati
S verifica di
italiano
piacere
diciamo Ah ma è finto è
[Musica]
finto sono stati i bulli ci stanno
scoprendo indietro indietro tirata
andiamo dai Bulli Come vi siete permessi
Bulli a farci questo scherzo Siete dei
grandissimi rispettosi e noi noi noi non
abbiamo fatto niente L'ha fatto la
maestra e poi chi se ne frega del
compito tanto il libro non vinceremo noi
ci avete distratto dal compito adesso
come facciamo sì e dobbiamo vincere noi
il libro non voi Voi non ve lo meritate
poch non ce lo meritiamo noi il libro
Noi siamo i più fighi di questa scuola
non viamo sicuramente
noi Ciao sono l'emoji di Anita sono qua
per ricordarvi che è appena uscito il
mio nuovo libro La città
stregata Se non ce l'avete ancora andate
subito a prenderlo perché i primi che lo
prenderanno riceveranno il regalo il
poster con me e Merlino autografato da
me con dietro l'alfabeto segreto con cui
condivideremo tanti messaggi assieme
prendetelo subito eh Eh sì dicevamo eh
il libro lo vincerete voi
[Musica]
Certo Noi siamo le più
brave e infatti ora ce ne torniamo a
scrivere il tema Così noi potremmo
vincere il
libro stanno arrivando Mi devo
nascondere
[Musica]
che cosa'è
stato
pulsanti
scorregge sono stati Bulli ci hanno
fregato di nuovo un altro scherzo dei
bulli Ora basta Dobbiamo finire il
nostro tema ok
[Musica]
è
quello no non toccarlo Che schifo Magari
porta le
malattie anche questo è finto Sì sono
stati i
bulli ecolo
libro deve essere nost iniziamo a
scassinare tu vai giù vai giù vai
[Musica]
giù si apre mi è venuta
unidea un topo ma ci serve una chiave
non un topo stai a
vedere come hai fatto del dopo funziona
sempre
ci sono Camo fto adesso Priamo il libro
Sì il libro è nostro ragazzi Il libro è
nostro Dobbiamo prenderlo il libro di
Anita tiralo fuori tiralo fuori piano
piano piano questo è prezioso è
bellissimo Abbiamo vinto noi è
bellissimo ed è
nostro Ora basta Noi abbiamo scritto il
nostro tema quindi andiamo a prenderci
il libro Sì esatto
[Musica]
Come vi siete permessi avete rubato il
libro è ingiusto Ah ma chi se ne frega
Tanto il libro ce l'abbiamo comunque noi
ce l'abbiamo
noi abbiamo vinto TIM Bully Vince non
avete neanche scritto il tema non potete
prendere il libro voi lo avete
rubato Ma non avete toccato le sbarre se
voi toccate le sbarre avrete altri 10 li
Sì sì sì è vero Sì vi basta toccare le
sbarre per avere altri 10 libri come 10
librio
ragazzi Aspetta Ti aiuto
io buttiamoli
dentro
No no Sì l' abbiamo preso noi il libro
abbiamo vinto noi Team secchioni si
migliori E voi cosa state aspettando
andate anche voi a prendere il libro è
ora disponibile in libreria e onl andate
subito a
[Musica]
prenderlo
h